our eye I was so young when I was in New
York I certainly rode a lot but last
time I was here I found it really
distracting there's I was hard to stay
indoors because I wanted to be out all
the time I think the most important
thing is to just get a ritual down
wherever you are process well there's
two parts to it there's the long-term
process of a novel and then there's the
daily stuff you know it's like planning
for a marathon you uh you set up your
training schedule you know you have your
idea and I plot it out I have I make a
huge outline of it and about and then I
work every day about 9:00 to 2:00 or
3:00 I have to get three pages done
every day and there's usually a point
about 150 pages in where everything
falls apart where all the plans are for
not the book has become something else
and I have a nervous breakdown and then
I submit to what the book has become and
I keep going and that's a terrible and
then a great time no one likes to be
around me during that
I don't know what to tell people I mean
I really think it's just when everyone
says it's a it's a willpower kind of a
game that there's because the weirdest
part in graduate school was that the
most talented writers were not the ones
who became writers it was the dog at
once and that that's actually talent to
I guess is just being willing to go
every day
and stay there until the pages appear
every day and not I tell this to my
students to I'm like I know you can
write a short story overnight but that's
not the job that's not a long-term skill
you need to write a short story over a
month every month and I think that's it
for everyone you know it was I was
coming from New York I couldn't afford
anything I was having a hard time
figuring how to be a writer here and
going to Montana was a very attractive
completely different plan and it worked
out great for me but I'm not sure it
helped my writing you know because you
have a committee of people who are all
so long young like you and don't really
know how to do it well either so it's a
funny committee to be as submitting your
work to and you have to really know be
confident in what you're doing
because I wasn't writing like anyone
else there and that was hard for me to
figure out and I think it would be and
it's destructive to a novel for sure
because you meet every week with part of
a novel that really what you should tell
you a novelist is keep going until you
finish the draft don't anyone
Oh in Montana yeah it was it was great
but then also it was pretty cold dark
winters I guess that helps novel-writing
too historically but it also helps
drinking you know at those times but
maybe that helps a novel too but I love
it I go I go every year
you know I stay for a long time I love
going to writers colonies and pastoral
settings where there's nothing to do but
either walk around or read a book or
work on your book and they all seem
helpful I'm going there in a month yeah
I can't wait you work all day and
produce so much work and it doesn't feel
like work it just feels like it feels
like when you start out writing and you
just want to write all the time and
you're just so excited about everything
you're doing it feels like that again
that's hard to recreate because a lot of
times it feels like a job like you're
building up something really huge